[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre invité a été premier ministre
ministre des affaires étrangères député
président de groupe à l'assemblée donc
la politique au plus haut niveau il
connaît bien mais c'est sur son rôle
d'élu de terrain qu'on a envie de se
concentrer aujourd'hui la vie politique
locale c'est son quotidien depuis
toujours il a été maire de
saint-herblain 12 ans maire de nantes 23
ans a porté d'engueulades comme diraient
certains il nous dira d'ailleurs s'il
s'est souvent fait engueuler et on
espère qu'il nous dira beaucoup d'autres
choses de lui parce que sa parole est
rare dans les médias pourquoi at il peur
des questions des journalistes le ton
médiatique est il un peu trop agressif
pour lui on va lui poser la question
bienvenue dans un monde un regard
bienvenue jean marc ayrault et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans ce lieu je le précise le dôme
tournons un lieu assez méconnu du sénat
un lieu qui se prête à les changes plus
qu'à la confrontation je vous rassure
tout de suite c'est vrai que vous faites
assez rare dans les médias pour quoi je
parlais d'un ton agressif est ce que
c'est vrai que ce ton médiatique vous
fait un peu peur d'abord je veux pas
être un commentateur de l'actualité au
quotidien ça m'intéresse pas je j'ai
pris d'autres d'autres chemins
après avoir exercé comme vous l'avez
rappelé pendant plus de 40 ans des
mandats publics c'est plus que presque
50 ans d'engagement politique mais dont
40 ans au moins deux mandats publics
donc j'estimais qu'il était temps aussi
d'arrêter de laisser la place à d'autres
de transmettre à d'autres et donc j'ai
pris d'autres voies d'autres chemins
d'engagement je suis président
aujourd'hui la fondation pour la mémoire
de l'esclavagé que j'ai contribué à
créer je suis aussi secrétaire général
de la fondation jean jaurès je suis dans
des fondations allemandes bon je
participe au débat public mais sous
d'autres façons et pas au quotidien et
pas comme un simple commentateur et de
façon un peu plus discrète je le disais
ce que d'un mot tout de même sur cette
atmosphère médiatique c'est vrai qu'elle
est est ce qu elle a évolué vous qui
avez connu plusieurs années de débats
est ce que vous y bien sûr qu'elle a
évolué tout le monde ne le sait la place
des réseaux sociaux qui joue un rôle
très important qui parfois se substitue
à la presse on devient presque son
propre
journalistes sans passer par le par les
organes d'une part par les médias ce qui
pose d'ailleurs des problèmes
démocratiques
et puis il ya la présence des chaînes
d'info continue et qui je crois a
beaucoup perturbé le climat politique
etc c'est un fait ça n'existe pas dans
tous les pays je viens d'allemagne
j'étais pendant quelques jours là au
mois d'octobre il n'y a pas ces chaînes
d'info continue et ça ça change
l'ambiance je crois pas que ce soit en
mille et terminant sa change l'ambiance
en mieux là les allemands viennent de
terminer une campagne électorale ils
sont en train de constituer leur
gouvernement il n'y a pas eu cette
agressivité dans les débats publics il
ya eu des confrontations tout à fait
intéressante il n'y a pas eu cette
agressivité l'extrême droite qui
malheureusement reçoit aussi des voix en
allemagne n'a pas pu imposer ses thèmes
dans le débat public il ya une débat
public beaucoup plus serein qu'en france
donc il faudrait aussi parfois regarder
ce qui se passe chez les autres parce
que nous on est rentré dans une sorte de
dérivé de caricature où les extrémistes
imposent leurs thèmes et je pense que
les grands partis démocratiques s'ils
sont en difficulté c'est aussi parce que
il ne s'assume pas et il assume pas
assez leurs convictions et ne savent pas
résister il se laisse parfois emporté en
courant derrière les extreme pensant
qu'ils garderont ainsi leurs électeurs
ce qui me paraît être une faute
politique grave qu'est ce qui vous y
fait venir à la politique vous cédez
l'adolescent je crois que ça commence je
commençais à ces jeunes enfin je
m'intéressais à la politique j'étais
dans j'ai commencé à m'engager que dans
mon lycée en 1968 j'étais en terminale
et j'étais dans le comité d'action lycée
à je suis arrivé à l'université juste
après et j'ai j'ai été déçu bien sûr
qu'ils aient pas eu de débouché
politique à toutes les revendications de
réformes sociales sociétales de mai 68
et donc j'ai cherché un engagement j'ai
regardé ce qu'il y avait sur le marché
entre guillemets j'ai pas trouvé dans
les partis d'extrême gauche ça
m'intéressait page et je voulais à parti
de gauche que je ne trouvais pas j'ai
donc attendu un peu pourquoi parti de
gauche c'était une évidence est
n'hésitez c'était mes convictions j'ai
lu dans votre univers familier le cij
que votre père était ouvrier agricole
votre mère couturière est oui j'étais
deux milieux modestes et donc j'étais
très attaché à la justice sociale à tous
les combats qu'ils allaient dans ce sens
mais j'habitais dans une commune rurale
près de cholet dans le maine-et-loire et
est donc j'ai beaucoup appris j'ai
beaucoup découvert notamment quand je
suis arrivé au lycée puis ensuite à
l'université et donc j'aspirais à ces
changements des changements en
profondeur de la société donc j'ai
regardé l'offre politique et finalement
c'est au moment où le parti socialiste
a connu une nouvelle renaissance au
congrès d'epinay lorsque les socialistes
se sont réunis qu'un nouveau départ a
été engagée que là j'ai adhéré donc
c'était en 1971 et puis il fait le fait
est que très vite j ai pris des
responsabilités
j'ai été élu très jeune à 26 ans
conseiller général et puis ensuite maire
de saint-herblain puis de nantes dont
c'est toute ma carrière toute ma vie
politique justement on va rester
quelques minutes si vous le voulez bien
sur cette expérience de maire parce que
c'est aussi cette expérience là qui nous
intéresse c'est encore d'ailleurs le
responsable politique le plus apprécié
des français il la figure du maire la
première fois que vous est élu maire
s'étant 77 à saint-herblain à la
périphérie de nantes donc vous est alors
le plus jeune maire de france d'une
commune de plus de 30000 habitants
est-ce que ça a été un moment fondateur
de votre parcours politique
ah oui complètement les comme je dis
souvent j'ai pas fait l'ena mais j'ai
fait mr maire de nantes et avant maire
de saintes est repris mais je dis pas ça
je peux pas porter de jugement de valeur
mais c'est vrai que c'est une école de
la vie où on apprend on n'est pas dans
la théorie on est dans la pratique et
puis là vous n'avez pas d'échappatoire
moi je me souviens que quand j'étais
maire de saint-herblain 40000 habitants
quand même mais je tenais des
permanences je recevais les gens et il y
avait un lien affectif qui se crée petit
à petit on répondait pas à tous mais il
y avait une proximité qui s'installe et
puis ça conduit à beaucoup d'humilité on
peut avoir beaucoup d'ambition un
programme des choses à faire des grands
projets mais si on ne règle pas les
problèmes du quotidien en même temps je
dis souvent
voir loin et agir près c'était un peu un
slogan que j'ai employé tout au long de
ma carrière de merde pendant 35 années
parce que je crois qu'il faut arriver à
faire les deux c'est d'avoir une vision
un projet et en même temps être attentif
à la vie des gens et qu'ils se sentent
représentés qui se sentent défendu et
écouter parce que ça a continué après
saint-herblain en 88 vous lancer à la
conquête de la mairie de nantes pour
succéder à
michel chauty maire rpr j'avais battu en
1977 à saint-herblain et la voulons pas
vous l'emportez au bras il se présente
pas mais je les remplace est deux fois
et nantes trois cent mille habitants
c'est pas évidemment les 40000 habitants
saint-herblain un exercice différent
c'est différent parce que évidemment la
proximité le que je pouvais vivre tous
les jours dans une commune de 40000
habitants va changer on va changer
d'échelle et donc il faut à faire
l'apprentissage de la gouvernance de
cette grande échelle tout en gardant le
contact dont progrès quand même ou pas
d'être un peu moins connectés au terrain
le fait d'être le maire d'une grève mon
expérience de saint-herblain a fait que
j'ai toujours veillé y compris danse le
mandat de cette grande ville que j'ai
continué à renforcer et à renaître parce
qu'elle était en difficultés économiques
elle perdait des habitants c'est une
ville en déclin et donc j'ai toujours
préservé le contact direct comment
comment vous faites là c'est une
question d'organisation de méthode de
concilier le travail de bureau de
réunion la présence à paris aussi vous
avez dit que j'avais été député
président du groupe parlementaire
pendant 15 ans donc à l'époque il y
avait le cumul des mandats qui était
possible j'ai réussi à articuler tout ça
et j'ai beaucoup travaillé en équipe
beaucoup délégué mais en vingt ans
délégué ça veut dire aussi arbitré ça
veut dire aussi dirigé et donc j'ai
appris à faire de la politique quand je
suis arrivé comme premier ministre
j'avais l'expérience parlementaire
presse de la gestion politique mais
j'avais aussi l'expérience de gestion
des d'une administration de grands
administration de direction des
fonctionnaires donc je ne me suis pas
senti dépaysé d'une certaine façon
certains disent qu'il faut revenir au
cumul des mandats possibles moi je suis
content j'ai été le premier ministre qui
a fait voter cette réforme est
l'argument qui est de dire on est coupé
du terrain quand on est parlementaire et
qu'on n'est plus élu local en fait le
cumul des mandats interdit le non cumul
des mandats a interdit la la
le cumul entre un mandat exécutif et un
mandat parlementaire mais ça n'interdit
pas d'être conseiller municipal
conseiller départemental ou conseiller
régional et puis il est possible dans
une carrière politique deux
successivement mer puis de devenir
parlementaire ou présidente départements
ou de régions dans la plupart des
démocraties et en particulier en europe
n'y a pas de cumul ça veut dire que les
gens sont moins enraciné ça veut pas
dire qu'il soit ma proche des gens donc
je pense qu'il faut faire attention à ne
pas revenir en arrière ce serait je
crois une régression pendant ses deux
mandats locaux vous allez aussi vous
faire remarquer au sein du parti
socialiste et donc gravir les échelons
au sein d'un parti politique nationale
historiquement très important pour le
pays là c'est encore un autre monde
c'est un monde plus dur peut-être où il
faut jouer des coudes non mais c'est ce
que j'ai connu au parti socialiste donc
dans toute cette période la période la
plus dynamique c'est celle où il y avait
des débats politiques des débats d'idées
et c'est vrai que quand je fais le bilan
dans la fin de cycle qu'a connu le parti
socialiste mais comme toutes les grandes
formations politiques c'est qu'on
n'était plus dans des débats de
personnes débat de conquête de pouvoir
individuel que dans le débat public et
dans le débat d'idées dans le débat
comment dire idéologique et c'est cette
déperdition qui peu à peu s'est
installée et qui a donné lieu à une
sorte de forme de professionnalisation
d'un politique on a vu des assistants
parlementaires devenir adjoint au maire
puis après devenir mère perd près de
devenir parlementaire ban qui n'avait
rien fait d'autre dans leur vie que de
la politique dans les appareils et je
pense que ça ça ça n'a pas aidé à garder
le contact et à garder l'authenticité de
show pense qu'aujourd'hui on a à nouveau
besoin de débat on a besoin d'idées on a
besoin de peu au fond pour la gauche en
particulier que la gauche se réinvente
et qui n'abandonne pas la bonne jambe en
donne pas ses ambitions de
transformation sociale est-ce que vous
avez préféré l'expérience locale l
expérience nationale
j'ai aimé les deux parce que je pense
qu'effectivement
d'avoir été premier ministre ou ministre
des affaires étrangères mais comme
premier ministre on est au coeur de
l'état oui on voit aussi les limites et
c'est vrai que les limites surtout quand
on est premier ministre deux ans c'est
ce qui a été mon cas ça a été souvent la
moyenne d premier ministre entre une
décision politique et son exécution sur
le terrain il ya souvent un temps
beaucoup plus long que la durée du
mandat de premier ministre vous n'avez
pas voir les résultats lorsque vous avez
été maire comme moi pendant si longtemps
ce que vous engagez ce que vous décidez
vous envoyer les résultats vous voyez
sur le terrain les choses qui ont été
transformés ce soit des grands projets
ou des modifications des conditions de
la vie quotidienne et donc ça c'est plus
gratifiant mais je pense qu'on ne peut
pas se passer de l'un et de l'autre je
ne vais pas opposer la politique locale
à la politique nationale la politique
locale n'est pas tout mais en même temps
je pense que si on veut réfléchir pour
l'avenir il est important que dans
l'exercice du pouvoir en particulier au
niveau de la présidence de la république
et du gouvernement qu on articule mieux
les décisions politiques nationales avec
les pouvoirs locaux avec le rôle des
maires en particulier qui sont
indispensables on le voit avec la crise
du coc vide on a bien vu que beaucoup de
décisions avaient été prises en haut
mais quand on voulait que ce soit
efficace il fallait les articuler avec
les acteurs locaux et quand s'est pas
fait et quelque chose qui ne fonctionne
pas est ce que le fait d'avoir eu ces
mandats locaux d'avoir été maire si
longtemps a fait de vous un premier
ministre différents et peut-être plus l
écoute des élus locaux juste louis sans
doute j'avais set j'avais 7 cette
conviction que toute politique nationale
ne pouvait être mise en oeuvre que si on
l'articulet avec les pouvoirs locaux je
prends un exemple la réforme des rythmes
scolaires je pense que ça a été une
déception pour moi parce que ça n'a pas
fonctionné comme ça aurait dû
fonctionner on pourrait même dire que ça
a été un échec ça a été un échec parce
que au départ ce que j'avais dit
d'ailleurs m'ont mise éducation
nationale il faut absolument mettre les
maires dans le coup les écoles c'est eux
les collèges sur les départements les
lycées les régions mais il est des
écoles primaire et maternelle c'est les
maires et donc si les maires sont pas
dans la boucle s'ils sont pas au départ
associé à la définition du projet ça ne
marchera pas je me suis repencher plus
précisément sur les mesures que vous
avez prises lorsque vous étiez aux
manettes et j'ai envie de données
numériques quelques-unes pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent et
vous me dites si je me trompe un hausse
de l' isf accroissement des droits de
succession hausse de la tva des hausses
dont l'objectif est évidemment de
renforcer la solidarité nationale avec
comme mesure l'augmentation de 25 % de
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire retour
légal de la retraite à 60 ans
augmentation du smic et du rsa
finalement les français ont un peu
tendance à l'oublier mais la première
partie du quinquennat hollande a bien
été à gauche absolument absolument moi
je suis partie et ensuite il ya eu une
forme de tournant il faut bien le dire
les contre les conditions de mon départ
on était bien analyser on a vu que il y
avait eu des choses qui n'avait pas
fonctionné ensuite qu'il y avait une
forme d' éloignement en particulier de
l'électorat populaire et de l'électorat
de gauche qui a exprimé sa déception
mais après vous c'est pas du championnat
de droite si non je dis pas que c'est un
cas kahn est droite mais il ya eu un
retrait de certains membres de certaines
ambitions transformatrices en
particulier a vu la loi travail il ya eu
la déchéance de nationalité finalement
ne s'est pas fait tout ça c'était pas
vous non ne riez pas tes non je ne je
n'aurais pas été dans cette direction
est jamais même engagé mais ça n'a pas
été suivie d'effet ensuite l'ambition
d'une grande réforme fiscale dans le
sens de la justice sociale donc moi je
me sentais comment dire mandaté par le
programme du président françois hollande
qui avait été présenté aux français au
moment des élections présidentielles de
2012 donc il ya des leçons à tirer tous
à l'échec il a bien des causes mais il
faut en analyser toutes les as tous les
aspects pour en tirer de toutes les
leçons pour l'avenir pourtant vous
restez ministre dans un gouvernement
après sept
alors j'ai nom sera ses produits
d'autres fois la jupe était premier
ministre il est aussi ministre étrangère
laurent fabius a été premier ministre
est en chêne mandat de premier ministre
à ministre sert la tige est survenu à
l'assemblée nationale quelques instants
quelques instants quelques mois et puis
à la fin du quinquennat françois
hollande m'a rappelé dans la dernière
partie du quinquennat et je ne pouvais
accepter que si c'était un poste
régalien donc le ministère des affaires
étrangères donnait beaucoup plus de
latitude beaucoup plus de marge de
manoeuvre et j'ai accepté de le faire
pensant que nous pouvions encore sauver
les choses que ce quinquennat pouvait se
terminer positivement bon on connaît la
suite
françois hollande ne s'est pas
représenté je le regrette mais c'est
ainsi mais un sentiment d'échec
personnel vous aussi c'est pas personnel
mais c'est collectif je pense moi je
suis engagé toute ma vie à gauche j'ai
pas en du tout envie qu'on abandonne ces
idées là je pense qu'au contraire
aujourd'hui avec les grands défis du
moment que ce soit la transition
énergétique pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique tout la
nécessité de préserver notre système
démocratique
là la pression que mettent les réseaux
sociaux le légat etc il ya énormément de
choses à faire et je pense que toutes
ces transformations de notre système
économique ne sont possibles que si en
même temps on met toujours plus de
justice sociale c'est pour ça que je
suis un social démocrate pour ça que je
suis de gauche et je crois que ces idées
là et n'ont pas perdu de leur importance
est de leur intérêt pour la société et
vous semble en danger la démocratie de
la même manière que la planète oui oui
je pense qu'on voit une tendance à la
polarisation à l'extrême elle est là la
radicalisation qui s'est produit un peu
partout pas seulement en france les
états unis en est un autre exemple où la
société quasiment coupée en deux je
pense qu'il faut faire très très
attention il ya une tendance aujourd'hui
à tout regarder sous le prisme l'islam
la sécurité l'immigration alors que bien
sûr ce sont des questions qu'il faut pas
négliger mais il ya aussi toutes les
questions économiques les questions
environnementales les questions sociales
qui devraient être aussi au même même
davantage au niveau plus élevé et qui ne
sont pas et je pense que c'est une
erreur parce que même si les français
sont préoccupés sont inquiets pour leur
avenir en même temps on voit bien que
quand on fait des enquêtes la fondation
jean jaurès dont je fais partie vient
d'en faire une chose qui porte sur 15000
personnes avec le cevipof et qui montre
la première préoccupation c'est l'avenir
économique c'est le pouvoir d'achat et
et de ça on ne parle pas beaucoup ou pas
assez alors on le dit et vous vous êtes
retiré de tous vos mandats est ce que
pour autant vous dire est que vous ne
fait plus de politique
je fais toujours la politique je suis un
citoyen engagé si je préside cette
fondation pour la mémoire de l'esclavagé
ce sont des questions toujours
d'actualité si je suis à la fondation
jean jaurès parce que je crois à l'idéal
social démocrate ou si je suis dans une
fondation allemande parce que je crois
aussi à l'idéal européen donc c'est une
autre forme d'engagement mais s'agissant
par exemple de nantes moi j'ai considéré
qu'il était important et qu'il était de
monde ward préparer ma succession donc
j'ai travaillé à la transmission
aujourd'hui juin à roland
oui je suis très heureux de qu'elle est
ailleurs été réélu a été élu la première
fois en 2014 réélu cette fois ci et
c'est important qu'on passe quand on est
un responsable politique le relais à
d'autres générations vous l'avez dit
vous êtes président de la fondation pour
la mémoire de l'esclavagé qui m'amène à
vous montrer un document qui nous a été
transmis par les archives nationales qui
sont nos partenaires sur sur cette
émission vous le reconnaissez le code
noir ou edith du roi je le dis pour nos
spectateurs ordonnance qui en mars 1685
va institutionnaliser l'esclavagé
légaliser les relations maître esclave
légiférer sur la condition des esclaves
en tant que maire de nantes vous vous
êtes engagé très vite très tôt sur ce
travail de mémoire sur le sujet il faut
dire que la traite négrière à nantes est
à l'origine de la déportation de plus de
500 mille esclaves c'est ça que dit ce
document pour vous pas ce document c'est
un acte politique extrêmement important
puisqu'il va institutionnaliser est
légalisée esclavage et considérer les
esclaves venus d'afrique et transporter
de force dans des bateaux dans les
colonies françaises
comme des biens meubles contre les
maîtres son total pouvoir sur eux qui ne
sont plus traitées comme des humains
alors que ce sont des humains et donc il
ya des résistances à l'esclavagé les
résistances sont d'abord les esclaves
eux mêmes qui n'ont jamais accepté leur
mise en service il ya des esprits
éclairés y compris dès les débuts de la
traite et de l'esclavagé qui moment par
exemple de la révolution française vont
se battre pour l'abolition de
l'esclavagé qui finiront par l'obtenir
en 1793 mais qui sera rétabli par
napoléon en 1802 et il faudra attendre
1848 c'est tardif pour que la france
abolisse enfin l' esclavage ça veut pas
dire que l'histoire s'arrête après la
colonisation va prendre le relais avec
toutes ces violences et ces brutalités
et il sera sa imprègne toute notre
histoire et ne pas connaître cette
histoire c'est une faute et je pense
qu'il est important et je le dis là nous
sommes à public sénat je n'oublie pas
que la dernière assemblée qui s'est
prononcé
en 2001 sur la loi taubira c'est le
sénat qui à l'unanimité a adopté cette
loi qui est une loi de reconnaissance
que la traite et l'esclavagé ce sont des
crimes contre l'humanité présidé cette
fondation pour la mémoire de l'esclavagé
ça aurait pu être une mission
relativement simple j'ai envie de dire
consensuel qui qui qui apaise les
tensions finalement s'aperçoit que c'est
aussi très électrique que le débat est
électrique autour de cette question
aujourd'hui ça vous surprend vous vous
attendiez ça ne surprend pas mais ça
veut pas dire pour autant il faut pas le
mener il faut même aller de façon
pédagogique c'est la raison pour
laquelle d'ailleurs à la suite de la loi
taubira cette histoire est maintenant
enseignée dans les programmes scolaires
le sénat qui nous accueillent ici
aujourd'hui
reçoit tous les ans les élèves qui
participent au concours de la flamme de
l'égalité donc il ya un travail qui se
fait qui n'a jamais été autant entrepris
au niveau de l'éducation de la
connaissance de cette histoire mais
aussitôt qu'on touche sur ces questions
c'est vrai qu'il ya des gens qui vont
tout de suite vous accuser de faire de
la repentance du mea culpa c'est pas ça
l'enjeu l'enjeu c'est que notre société
recherche qui va faire converger les
citoyens ensemble qui va nous faire
converger on a besoin c'est même l'un
vers ce que plus plus le temps avance
plus le soleil segmenter la société
c'est quand même sur la base de la
vérité la vérité historique pour ça que
je crois beaucoup à la nécessité de
poursuivre le travail de recherche la
loi taubira la halle a souhaité
également de la recherche se développe
davantage la connaissance historique des
faits eux mêmes et pas être sur des
approximations ou il ya différentes
manières de se remémorer or tout le
monde n'est pas d'accord sur la
fusillade mémoire la mémoire c'est une
façon de ceux de célébrer ou de
commémorer ou de se recueillir ça c'est
important dans une société il ya des
moments forts et en même temps il faut
baser ce travail sur une connaissance de
l'histoire des faits de plus en plus
précises prenons un exemple l'exposition
napoléon à l'occasion des 200 ans de
sama elle n'avait pas prévu
au départ de parler du rétablissement de
l'esclavagé a eu des réticences à le
faire considérant que c'était secondaire
puis finalement la fondation pour la
mémoire d'esclave âge que je préside a
fait son travail a interpellé les
organisateurs de l'exposition qui
finalement ont accepté de d2 qu'on
apporte notre contribution mais cette
contribution ne l'avons pas fait sur des
approximations nous avons a fait appel à
des historiens qui ont donné tous les
éléments d'information et qui ont fait
que le visiteur qui venait à la ville
est allée voir une exposition mais avait
tous les éléments d'appréciation et
notamment la partie qui concernait le
rétablissement de l'esclavagé au lieu
d'aborder d'aborder d'apporter de la
polémique
cette contribution à contraire apaiser
les esprits qui ont compris le mécanisme
qui avait fait que napoléon avait
rétabli l'esclavagé dans sa volonté de
puissance coloniale qu'il avait décidé
de développer donc vous voyez on peut
faire oeuvre utile travailler à une
mémoire partagée à une mémoire commune
mais de temps en temps il ya des actes
politiques forts moi je pense à un acte
politique mais les déboulonnage de
statut par exemple c'est sa naïveté
politique très fort qui n'a pas du tout
fait consensus et vous étiez par exemple
pour rebaptiser la salle colbert à
l'assemblée nationale colbert ce n'est
qu'une salle 1 j'avais suggéré
corneilhan parle d'actes politiques bien
sûr il faut des actes politiques fin moi
je suis pas pour détruire les statuts ou
déboulonner les statues c'est pas ma
position c'est pas la position de la
fondation non plus mais c'est normal
qu'une société s'interroge sur ce
qu'elle veut mettre dans l'espace public
une mairie qui va donner le nom d'une
rue ou d'une place ou qui va décider de
mettre tel ou tel statut dans tel
endroit où dans un musée c'est son choix
c'est la même chose pour la république
et ça ça doit faire consensus mais ça
doit faire aussi oeuvre pédagogique et
donc notre notre objectif c'est de voir
comment on peut créer du commun et voyez
quand mais de temps en temps il faut des
actes forts la loi taubira c'est un acte
fort mais quand jacques chirac président
de la république au vel d'hiv
assume au nom de la république la
responsabilité de l'état français donc
de la france dans la déportation des
juifs ça a choqué certains mais c'est un
acte politique dont il peut être fier et
qui au fond n'a pas desservi la france a
au contraire renforcer l'unité nationale
c'est un acte fort aujourd'hui un acte
politique fort aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est d'assumer ce que c'est à dire
notre histoire dans sa plénitude dans ce
qu'elle est dans sa totalité ne pas
faire la guerre des mémoires ou la
concurrence des mémoires mais de faire
en sorte que notre héritage politique
celui des lumières peut s'accorder avec
la vérité aussi sur l'histoire qui est
notre seul dans notre passé non pas pour
culpabiliser mais pour essayer d'être
plus forts ensemble et affronter les
défis du du futur et si on fait ça avec
de temps en temps des moments par
exemple jacques chirac j'ai rappelé
c'est lui qui a 2 désigne souhaite
désigner la journée du 10 mai une
journée de commémoration sur l esclavage
françois hollande a poursuivi en
préconisant la création d'une fondation
sur la mémoire de l esclavage dont il ya
des actes comme ça le président macron
qui a pris des décisions concernant la
guerre d'algérie ce aussi des moments
forts chaque président à mon avis h des
moments forts doit poser des actes et le
faire courageusement en respectant
l'histoire et en s'appropriant cette
histoire et en la faisant partager à
tous les français ça veut dire aussi
résister quand je vois certaines dérives
aujourd'hui qui contribue à réhabiliter
le maréchal pétain
elle est à l'état de vichy je suis
effrayé et donc il faut tenir bon il
faut pas céder et quand on sait des
concours derrière les haies de marine le
pen monsieur zemmour on fait une faute
contre la république donc savoir
résister si aussi être républicain jean
marc ayrault on va passer à notre
séquence photo
j'ai cette première photo françois
mitterrand figure politique majeur pour
vous on est alors en 1994 il a joué un
rôle clé pour vous mais très
concrètement sa visite par exemple
pendant la campagne des municipales à
saint-herblain en février 1989 va vous
donner un coup de pouce
[Musique]